how do we put our eggs in your basket
because we are we're relying on your
ethical and moral standards with the
general intelligence that you're
building as with anyone who would be
building what we would be relying on
here yeah you're relying on the
community not just me personally I mean
if in the unlikely event like I were
invaded by Martian mind virus and went
batshit crazy and became malevolent I
mean there's a loads of other
contributors to these projects so it's
about seeding it a community of people
who are are thinking in somewhat of a
shared way and aiming to develop things
in a benevolent manner and what are the
guiding principles of your community
that make it ethically and morally just
grounded and that we can trust that sex
drugs and rough sex drugs are not here
oh yeah yeah besides those besides that
yeah I think I mean an abstract level
the ethical principles I've written
about are basically joy growth choice
and continuity and I think all of these
have have an important value in the
practical context I mean we're trying to
promote happiness and and doing good
them and we try to have a work
environment and the community that
that's fun to be in I mean we're trying
to grow and expand rapidly and create
new patterns great new things new new
technologies new what new ways of being
choice means you know we want everyone
to have agency and that that's an
important part of the whole
decentralized ethos there shouldn't be a
few elites control everything and
continuity means you want to respect the
patterns of history as well as creating
new patterns and this includes like
persisting human beings into the end of
the future instead of replacing them
with
for a eyes it also includes being
respectful of you know historical
cultures that exist now and then certain
people are are very tied in to and of
course values like these are very
nebulously defined though and sort of
interpreting what they mean it's part of
what we're the community does
[Music]